all right so what's your 4e they're
going back to where you wrote this and
if you are if you haven't already put a
big box around it okay
we're gonna use this one derivative to
get all the ways that we need with some
of the stuff we remembered from earlier
today so cos x we're gonna get a strip
you can anyone remind me it's cos x cold
it's an abbreviation for something
what's an abbreviation for cosine what's
the cut that's the code is also an
abbreviation what static in previous
unit complimentary right this is the
complement of sine okay now once you
remember I'll do it in um I'll do it in
degrees cuz I know it's easier for a
Bray's to handle for now if I had sine
20 degrees right if you had you
calculated there you could say that's
exactly the same as cos of the
complement of that which in this case
would be 20 degrees and what adds up to
90 so 20 and 70 right so you could
verify this on your calculator as long
as your calculator is in the correct
mode and you can do this for any number
sign over you know 35 is going to be cos
of 55 right you can do this for anything
okay now we can take this into
trigonometry land up here in radians by
saying that cause of something is sine
of its complement now this is really
tricky in degrees we would say you've
got 70 by saying 90 degrees take away
whatever your other angle was in this
case it was 20 right now we're not in
degrees we're trying to do everything in
radians right so how do I say this
but in radians I won't say 90 degrees
for starters I'll say what's the
equivalent think think what's the
equivalent it's play on to thank you and
then in this case when I'm subtracting I
don't have like some 20 degrees or 35
degrees I have any angle you like so
therefore I'm just going to say X like
whatever angle that is okay now this
looks like it's made our task harder but
it's actually made it easier I want you
to look carefully again at 1b in the
review questions we did can you look
back turn back a page if you need to we
did it just at the start is lesson
what skill what knowledge did we pull on
to differentiate that function to the
power of seven what do we do we use
chain rule right cuz you like flannel
raises the power seven expand and this
is exactly the situation we have here I
can use chain rule to make mincemeat of
this right there's an outside function
and there's an inside function what is
the outside function it's sign right
there it is right there that's on the
outside literally on the outside what's
the inside function PI on two minus X
this here so let's do it one step at a
time we just worked out what the
derivative the outside function is so
sine is going to turn into cuz right
this thing stays the same just like it
always does within the function way to
go you've done the outside what's the
derivative of this inside point think
carefully
now this pi/2 is just like the negative
four in that original function right
does it change alpha just changes where
you are right this is the part of
matters and the coefficient is negative
one so I multiply this whole thing by
negative
wouldn't pound to equals again yeah if
you wanted to you could write that angle
there yeah it's kind of like even though
I can write it as pi times 2 to the
negative Y it doesn't actually help me
in fact just ignore it because it's a
constant almost done here
right this thing here this power 2 minus
X we introduced it so we could turn
things in terms of something I know
about right but we can use that same
fact about cosine of this pi onto - that
PI on 2 minus PI on 2 minus X that's the
complement of the continent what would
that bit won't help me out expansive
brackets for with that - at the front it
would just be BX right why because -
plan - that's going to become 0 and then
what happens here your double negative
right plus X of course the complement of
20 is 70 and the comedor 70 takes you
back to 20 right so therefore I can take
this and I can convert it back into now
it's 1 and on the colors here will help
you
that's okay thank you did you get them
okay yeah what's going on will cause X
right we had it just before he got it
but up like so what's the gradient start
off at for this guy right there at the
top what's the gradient the gradient
it's zero right because you've got that
horizontal tangent we're talking about
before as soon as you start going is it
decreasing or increasing it's decreasing
which is why the gradient should be
negative that's why it's minus sine X
lot regular sine X that makes sense and
then of course down here you've got
another station are you talking about I
just didn't want to write it so message
that's the basic reason this is that do
agree like riding up with that it's the
same thing they are equivalent but this
is just easier to so if you put a box
around this I'd love you also to put a
box around this the duty of sine is cos
but the derivative of cars is minus sine
this is a source of frustration for
calculus students all around the world
because it's so easy to mess up but this
is why I emphasize the importance of
thinking really hard because memory is
the residue of thought if you think heft
about this you will get it in some time
one last one and then you can we did
same when it cuz we need ten right now
are you looking back at the review
questions and are you suspicious now cuz
I gave you three I gave you three
differentiation examples right a simple
one I gave you the chain rule why do you
think I gave you chain rule
because of because of this right we just
used the chain rule and then the one see
what was the third one I gave you you
had to use that because what's 10 X 10 X
is a fraction right it's sine over cuz
so I am going to stop right here and I'm
gonna see if you can disentangle this
guy right here see what you get